[Musique]
bonjour hélène bonjour d'amiens tout
d'abord dans la presse elle a eu une
réaction aux mutineries donc qui ont
éclaté hier au burkina faso où des
soldats disent vouloir le départ des
chefs de l'armée plus de moyens pour
lutter contre les djihadistes d'après
awa 4 serra les mutins à existe
également que des mesures soient prises
pour soulager les parents et les proches
des soldats morts ou blessés au combat
le site d'info burkinabè rappelle que
ces tensions interviennent au lendemain
d'une journée mouvementée où des
manifestants ont réclamé entre autres la
démission du président roch marc
christian kaboré le soutien aux forces
de défense et de sécurité mais aussi à
la junte au pouvoir au mali qui est visé
par des sanctions communautaire dans un
pays qui a déjà connu une flopée de
mutinerie le pays exprime sa
préoccupation de voir ressurgir le
phénomène
à un moment le burkina est confronté à
une profonde crise sociopolitique le
journal juge les premières les dernières
mutinerie en date d'autant plus
inquiétante que leur impact pourrait
s'avérer désastreux précisément pour la
lutte contre le terrorisme
il demande donc d'éviter je cite de
tirer sur l'ambulance tout en appelant
le président kaboré à prendre conscience
que son pays va très mal à travailler à
réparer les torts et les manquements
dont pu être victimes les soldats à
sécuriser le pays et à mettre un terme à
la corruption ce cancer qui provoque je
cite toujours des actes susceptibles de
plonger le pays dans le chaos total
le quotidien burkinabè damien demande
aussi au chef de l'état de mettre un
terme aux mesures liberticides et de
respecter le droit à l'information
casser le thermomètre ne fera pas
baisser la fièvre prévient-il à la une
également l'envoi d'équipements
militaires occidentaux en ukraine pour
faire face au risque d'une attaque de la
part de la russie qui qui déploie aussi
des armes dans la région alors que
chaque côté accuse l'autre de faire
monter la pression le quotidien espagnol
el país précise que les états unis le
royaume uni et les pays baltes approuve
la livraison d'armes défensives à kiev
mais que l'allemagne elle oppose son
veto aux expéditions en provenance de
pays tiers le wall street journal
attribue la position de berlin à sa
dépendance énergétique vis à vis du gaz
russe une dépendance que le quotidien
américain lee à la décision de fermer
toutes les centrales au charbon
allemandes d'ici 2038 et au choix des
gouvernements successifs de ne pas
construire d'infrastructures pour
importer le gaz naturel liquéfié qui est
plus cher en provenance des principaux
pays exportateurs comme le qatar et les
états unis la presse internationale qui
revient ainsi largement ce matin sur la
mort du couturier français thierry
mugler disparu hier à l'âge de 73 ans le
film tonnes pause salue le style hyper
femina de ses créations qui ont parfois
été critiqué précisément pour la vision
de la féminité qu'elle pouvait véhiculer
des vêtements manifeste audacieuse et
spectaculaire d'après le magazine
américain rolling stones qui ont séduit
des artistes tels que diana ross david
bowie lady gaga ou encore beyoncé enfin
des nouvelles de la coupe d'afrique des
nations et des rencontres d'hier on
commence par la victoire de la tunisie
face au nigeria en 8e de finale et à la
prestation des aigles de carthage a
visiblement séduit la presse qui les a
trouvé magnifique héroïque en
particulier leur capitaine et youssef
msakni qui a expédié son équipe en quart
de finale grâce à un joli but prochain
rendez vous samedi vous l'avez dit face
au burkina faso également qualifié grâce
à une victoire à la pyrrhus dixit le
pays qui expriment des sentiments mêlés
après la journée
hier d'un côté la joie après la
qualification des étalons face aux
panthères du gabon après tirs au but 7 à
6 et de l'autre l'inquiétude après le
crépitement des armes au petit matin au
burkina faso et puis alors les comores
eux ils affrontent aujourd'hui le
cameroun en huitièmes de finale une
issue inespérée impôts un pays qui
n'avait pas de sélection nationale il ya
encore 16 ans dans l'équipe le
sélectionneur amiable ou raconte
l'histoire d coelacanthe quittaient leur
surnom damien d'un poisson à nageoires
charnue leur aventure a débuté en 2005
avec des joueurs issus de la diaspora
comorienne à marseille là où vit une
grande la grande majorité un des
comoriens de france à peu près cent
mille personnes aujourd'hui hélas pour
eux les comoriens jeu de malchance pour
cette première participation à la can
puisque douze membres de la délégation
sont positifs au kobus 19 dont deux de
ses gardiens de but d'après as bariza
qui demande à ce que les joueurs soient
retestés le site d'info comoriens veut
en avoir le coeur net 1 d'autant que
chez les lions indomptables seuls 4,4
qu'ovide ont été recensés mais quelle
que soit l'issue du dépistage comme du
match le site considère que cette
première participation est déjà en soi
une grande victoire et nous on leur
souhaite bonne chance coelacanthe oui
vous vous l'avez dit donc à deux
gardiens qui sont co vis dès le
troisième blessé autrement dit les
comores n'ont plus le gardien mais faut
jouer le match ce soir quitter bien
remplacer le gardien par un joueur
lambda mais vous allez voir que
l'entraîneur des gardiens des comores
est plutôt philosophe écouter on a eu
des potentiels gardien voilà c'est assez
cocasse on rigole ça c'est cocasse parce
qu'on préfère le prendre comme ça
maintenant on va se battre avec avec nos
valeurs avec avec tout ce qu'on tout ce
qui nous a amenés jusqu'ici jusqu'à
présent le gardien
on n'a pas encore déterminé et de toute
façon même si on avait déterminé je le
dirai pas voilà on leur souhaite bonne
chance merci beaucoup à l aine merci à
vous d'avoir choisi france 24 on se
retrouve dans un quart d'heure pour un
nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
m